before we start with the talker just
wanna give a short introduction about
myself so I'm one of the contributors
also maintainer of scotch and yeah you
can tell me Benjamin goes on on github
and during the day on the head of data
science of the balloon office of New
Yorker and that's the fashion company
not the magazine and you don't need to
write on anything because I'll give you
the link to the tour to to the get up of
scotch and so on at the end of the talk
so just relax and listen and yeah before
we start I have a question for the
audience so who among you is a data
scientist
okay that's almost everyone but who
among you is a deep data scientist yeah
so at the end of this talk
you're all gonna be deep data scientists
but you don't have to take it from me
you can take it from someone with a
little bit more authority than me
so this is a young Luca I think most of
you will know him and yeah when you saw
Scott she said okay every data
scientists can now be a deep data
scientist and by the end of the talk I
hope you understand why that is so just
some basic facts about Scott so it's a
open source everyone can work on that
and it's you know I think quite popular
people are asking questions you have
really nice and answering them so at
least that's my impression you can also
ask on Stack Overflow and it's also
quite mature so we have to first commit
in July 2017 we have three main
contributors I know that it's used in
production and hasn't failed so far we
have a bunch of examples you have some
notebooks that you can test out
locally or on google collab and we have
an extensive documentation so I think
yeah it's really ready to be used and
just a few words even though it might be
boring but about the philosophy so first
of all our main goal was to have
something that's as compatible as
possible with SK learn so I will explain
to you later what that means we wanted
to have a library that is hackable
because we know a cape I thought is
something that really allows you to try
out different crazy things and we didn't
want to restrain you in that way also we
don't hide Python so that's maybe you
were asking me what's one of the
differences to say something like err us
in Paris is something like a more
all-encompassing and it has its own API
that you know you might not even need to
touch the underlying frameworks but
Scott you will have to use just normal
Python code but that was our goal
and also we said okay we don't want to
reinvent the wheel and that's also
something that's been really driving us
when we are developing Scott so he is
just a small overview so we have Scott
but we reuse a lot of stuff on from
Python and from SK learn so from the
Python side we have the modules so you
will have to write your own Python
modules the same way as you usually do
you can take datasets so for instance
from taught revision if you want to do
some science we use the data loaders so
all of the stuff that you know all the
advantages of their loaders are still
there and learning rate schedules for
instance from PI torch we also use from
the SK downside we take the API we go
into more details about that later you
can use pipelines you can use feature
unions with scorch you can do the grid
search and everything else that you know
and love about psychic learn you can use
cross-validation you can use all the
metrics that are inside learn you don't
have to implement it yourself and from
the Scotch side we provide annual net
repre
similar to an SDM
from soccer blonde we provide a bunch of
useful callbacks and we provide a way to
easily build seal eyes yes if you help
us for different stuff that commonly
occurs and as I said we have a bunch of
examples and notebooks that you can draw
inspiration from so just if you will so
why was it so important for us to not
reinvent the wheel we also we wanted to
to be able to start right away with
scotch so and you have to learn as few
new concepts as possible so that was one
of our goals you wanted to keep the
complexity of the code base down so for
instance we don't implement any metrics
of our own because we can reuse the
metrics on psychic learn and we don't
want to have any lock-in effect so if
you're using scotch and you find that
the performance is lacking you can just
switch it out for any sq learn estimator
and it should just work and on the other
hand if you say okay you want to
experiment a little bit with scotch but
no you're done with it you can just take
out the module and then just work but
that may be I don't know trace it with a
JIT and then use it separately
completely without scorching should just
work most of the times so one of the
main advantages I think that Scotch
brings you is the reduction of
boilerplate code so if you have used
pythons in the past you know okay in
like writing the fit loop writing the
validation loop that's always I mean a
little bit annoying it's always the same
code basically but it's also easy to do
mistakes there so you don't need to read
this but this is basically a training
loop with pure Python with some
validation mixed in and then some
logging about the outputs and as you can
see it's quite a lot of code actually
and I will show you the same thing with
scorch so that's it so you just
important you will net classifier you
will define your module as you would
always do when you're just using Python
and then you can pass the module to the
neural net classifier you can set some
parameters on the module for instance
like the number of units so if your
module has
nann units argument you can just pass it
on like that with a double underscore
notation that you probably know from
socket learn and then we have a bunch of
things that you might usually want to
change like the number of epochs
learning rate batch size the device is
also just one place to change it and
then you just call net outfit X&Y so I
think it's yeah very nice and easy way
to use it and if you're a psycho burn
user that should all be familiar to you
so what do you get when you call an apt
outfit this is what you would get for a
classifier so you get a nice lock from
the training that shows you the epochs
it shows your training loss into an
internal cross-validation split so that
you know okay if I have some holdout
data
what would my validation does look like
what would my accuracy on the validation
set look like and also the duration and
all of that is very easy to modify I
will show to you later and by the way
all the code that I'm showing to you
this an accompanying Jupiter notebook to
this so you can just check it out later
on and run all the code you will see
that it works exactly as I advertised it
so let's now go to this part of the
cycle learn compatibility so what does
it mean - like compatibility with SK
learn so first of all as I mentioned
earlier you can just use the metrics
from a scalar so let's say you have a
binary classification task and maybe
accuracy is not the best metric to look
at maybe you want to use rock auc so you
can just import that from SK learn and
then from scotch you have this thing
called epoch scoring and it's a callback
and for the codec you just pass the
scoring function and here in this case
we also tell it that lower is better as
false because you want to have a high
AUC and then you just pass the callbacks
to the UN that classifier and then you
will automatically get the AUC score and
your output so that's for example how
can we use the metrics and if you know
ask a little bit you know that for
example if you're on a grid search you
can just pass the string like this so
that's also possible and then of course
if you're losing as using a scaler and
you know that there are a bunch of
methods that you would usually expect to
be there so we have already seen fit
that's there you also have partial fit
so what will this give you that allows
you to continue your training but the
same estimator so instead of doing cold
start you can have a warm start and just
go on training you have to predict and
the predict progress or if you're
working with a classifier the difference
is that the letter will give you the
probabilities and then there are some
things that are important for example if
we're doing grid search like get power
and set parents you can just clone the
net you can call things like cross
validate and you can be sure that it all
just works then of course if you're an
avid SK learn user you also know
pipelines and feature unions and this
will also just work with scorch so you
can for example if you are in put it as
not well scaled you can just import the
standard scaler put that into the
pipeline then in the next step you put
the net and you can just call fit
predict predict program that will just
work with it with scotch and support
with NES trailer and estimator and we
also make sure that pickling works so I
know it's maybe not the preferred method
to serialize Python code but sometimes
if you have a whole estimator within the
pipeline and so on and you want to save
the whole of it so that you can load it
later on it's often more convenient to
use pickle and yeah we make sure that
this all works and even if you do for
instance train on a machine with a GPU
and want to later on to inference on a
machine to the CPU this will also work
so there's something that can sometimes
get a bit annoying
and then this is something that a lot of
people ask when you are using Python
yeah I want to do a grid search and I
don't know how to do it and if you try
to write it on your own that's really
error-prone and there are a lot of
things that can go wrong there but
fortunately we have scorched so we can
just use grid search from scikit-learn
and I will explain to you a little bit
how this works yes so as you can see we
have at the top we have a Justin on a
high-touch module and it takes two
arguments so the number of units and the
dropout rate and maybe those are some
parameters some hyper parameters that
you want to try to grid search and how
would you do that well you can just pass
on module double underscore which will
tell Scott R okay please dispatch this
to the pan touch module and then you can
just pass on any values so for the non
units we might want to check 10 20 and
50 and for the dropout rate in my check
zero or 0.5 and the same concept with
the double underscore notation works for
everything else so for instance you
might have a momentum term on your
optimize alright and you might want to
check this tool so you just put an
optimizer double underscore momentum and
then you can put in the values you want
grid search and of course you can also
just grid search the normal high power
parameters on the newer net that I
showed you earlier like the number of
epochs batch size whatever you want and
then you put all of that into a grid
search CD from scikit-learn and you call
fit with your data and it will just work
so might be asking yourself ok what can
I get searched on and the answers
basically everything so we already saw
that on the newer Nets you can with such
learning rate marks epochs and edge size
on the module you can grid search any
parameter that you put into the in it
so it's just your imagination that's
that's limiting you with the optimize I
also showed you you can try out
different things you can try out
different things with the criterion we
also have the data loader which is just
the normal high touch data loader so you
have some arguments on that I don't know
you want to check whether shuffling the
training data helps or not you can do it
search on that and I think what's also
very interesting is that you can grid
search on the call banks so I'm not sure
if there's anything out there that
allows you to do that so if you have
some callbacks let's say for gradient
clipping and you want to grid search
different that is to clip-on that's
absolutely possible so you would just
give you a call like a name like my
callback and then you can just pass any
parameter and it will work with your
callbacks so this provides a lot of
flexibility when doing grid search or
any of the other kinds of searches that
they are and yeah so I'm using that a
lot and it's yeah I think it's a very
unique feature of scotch and as I said
earlier scotch is totally replaceable so
if you think that your net is not doing
a good job for you you can just swap it
out with any other Esqueda estimator so
here for example I want to try the
logistic regression or the K neighbors
classifier I can put it into a grid
search as well pass the pipeline and
then I can just see which of these
estimators will do the best job for me
so if you are finding that new and ads
won't do it for you you should just use
logistic regression or K neighbors
classifiers and sometimes very just
better and also something that should
work just fine is using distributed grid
search so you can use dusk and the
parallel back end there's a little bit
more detail and documentation and but
yeah so what this will do is it will
distribute
good search across the cluster so if you
have ten machines each one will run one
of the parameter settings and you will
be finished much faster and on top of
those we have a few more additions that
we just found people find really useful
so I want to talk a little bit about
those so you probably know that entitled
the best way to save the parameters is
through the steak ticked because this is
independent of the code so it's a law
forward compatible but changes and you
can absolutely do that so we provide
several ways to do this so for instance
you can just call save parents and then
the eff pans will indicate the
parameters of your module but the
optimizer might also have something
that's worth saving so that you can save
that and then the next time you can just
load that the load parents that method
and then you can continue working within
your net and this is a little bit of a
safer method to persist your neural net
and at the same time we also provide a
callback that's called checkpoint so you
can just do checkpointing and what's
interesting here is you can just
indicate what well YouTube monitor so if
you want to only do a checkpoint when
you reach the best leather gloss you
just put in this way that lost best and
it will do this but also say you have
added your area under the curve the
score you can also just indicate that
anything that your log you can use to
monitor and then later on you can also
load from the checkpoint so that's also
very convenient for example if you are
training your net and then you want to
save the best state and then continue
from that it's very easy to do in scorch
and there's also a bunch of
documentation of your different options
that you have there
and one more thing that we provide is we
handle a lot of different data types so
usually the PI thought you should use
the pilot or data set which is of course
a bunch of advantages but also torturous
be that your data is in the different
formats so if you want to switch easily
to using Esqueda run without you and
that's you probably have your data and
then an array and that's fine the Scotch
we handle non Padres they also handle
congas data frames or CSR sparse
matrices so that's also fine and then we
just found that often with new nets you
have a little bit more complex data so I
know you might have your your text data
which is then can have different lengths
so you want to pack this into the data
as well so for that you can use the
dictionary that just contains different
fields with your data and Scotch will
also handle that so and then it will
just format those to your forward method
of the module with the same name of the
arguments and it's very convenient so I
use that a lot if you are having a
little bit more complex data you should
look at dictionaries then as I said we
provide a bunch of context I already
mentioned the learning rate schedulers
and our PI torture implements a lot of
learning rate schedules already so you
can use those but you can also good
search runs those and so on I always
showed your scoring's you have already
stopping checkpointing we can freeze
parameters if you have some kind of pre
trained net and on master we now have
the possibility to integrate with 10
support so all of the locks that I
showed you will also be visible on 10
support and it's just yeah I don't have
a lot of time but just very quickly so
we a provide some help us if you have
some training scripts you probably know
that it's can be really annoying to
write a parser for the arguments and so
on and then writing they have
different arguments and usually dozens
of arguments so you will just forget
about some of those and so on and with
scotch is really easy you can just add
those to basically just this line here
and if you do that you get the help
automatically from your dog strings so
here we have the arguments for the new
annette we have some arguments from from
your multi will and so on so you get the
helpful free and then you can just call
it from the command line and change all
of the arguments from the command line
number of epochs and you can change the
arguments from your module you can even
pass in python objects there's a string
and it just works so if you're having a
bunch of training scripts and wasting a
lot of time with parsing the arguments
and so on you should give score to try
and yeah it's also easily hackable and i
think i will skip this section cuz i
don't have a lot of time anymore about
our society so online you can look at
this so we really don't restrain you and
what you can do with scotch
so let me wrap up so when should you not
use scotch so when you have very very
custom Python code that does a lot of
crazy things with a lot of
interconnected stuff then you might not
be very happy with scotch or when you do
something like reinforcement learning we
haven't really used it so i think it
will probably be difficult if you want
to write code that's agnostic to the
backend you should also probably look
for something else so if you want to
switch to tensorflow it's not going to
be possible with scotch if you have no
need at all for the SK learn API you can
also probably skip scotch and of course
we will have a very slight performance
overhead so if you're really all about
performance you might also consider not
using scotch but yeah I think I already
explained to you what you gain so you
gain the a scalar an API and all the
benefits that come with that most Python
workflows should just work Scott you
have
a bunch of boilerplate you have to
standardized codes and as I showed you
we have a lot of utilities that you
might use in your day-to-day work if you
search in one job you can come to me
after the talk we are looking for a data
scientist and software developers and
yeah here are the links so yeah thank
you very much thank you we have time for
questions is there any question sorry
yes hello thanks for the nice talk
before you mentioned the performance
overhead I already had a question in my
mind how big or slide is it really do
you have a number yeah so we have a
strip to test this and it's based on
amnesty I mean of course it's it's not
the biggest data set but that was the
point okay we try to use a small data
set and see what how much of a
difference it is and I believe it's much
below 10% and I think usually when
you're using something like I taught you
will have much bigger data sets so you
will spend much more time on actually
doing so in the pipe arch world when
you're using your other computation so
on so the bigger your data the less time
you are the less the percentage of all
matters with scorch because that is
basically a fixed overhead if you have a
very very small data set then you will
notice the difference the question yes
[Music]
thanks a lot for the talk a mother
actually any plans to migrate existing
SK learn modules to PI torch from numpy
to be able to run them on the GPU not
only just neural networks and I can't
tell you about that because I think
there are other people are more
knowledgeable about this at least it's
not in the scope of
because we don't provide any pre-built
modules and so on so if you looking for
ready-made modules like CNN's language
models and so on you should look
elsewhere we are mainly focused on
providing this utility this wrapper and
so on and if you find some modules that
I don't know implement logistic
regression with PI torch on GPU you will
probably be able to use them as
scholarships fine but it's not something
that we provide ourselves so the
question was it alright yeah Miguel
[Music]
just a small question how does scorch
work and Psyche learn when you have GPUs
or where you have multiple GPUs and you
want to train in parallel or like
distribute it so if you want to do
something like data parallel and lotto
parallel you have to do it yourself so
it's something that you would do on your
modules side right so you can say okay I
want to sign it here I want to send it
there then you have to take care of it
so Scotch won't help you with that as I
said the only thing that we can help
with this training a couple of models at
the same time through the parallel back
end of tasks you have a question thank
you
[Music]
the the GPU and scikit-learn thingy
there are DVD the other side of the
efforts that are going on is that in
nonpoint now you have the array function
protocol and any anybody who any any
library that complies with that can work
with non pas and then we extensively
from scikit-learn side obviously used
Syfy and numpy and the one that does
numpy on GPU like one of them is Cooper
and the idea is that scikit-learn should
accept something that acts that
implements are a function protocol and
we don't do low-level stuff or we don't
make sure that it's unknown by then you
just pass something which is a coupe IRA
instead of an honourary and it runs on
GPU but it's it's kind of far from being
finished and implemented but that's kind
of another question if time know 1/2
what question actually I know if you
have examples in your slides but I don't
really got the how do you basically use
a dataset within Scourge yeah yeah so
you can just pass it to the fit function
and it will usually work the only
restriction that we have is that the so
you can with a torch data set you have
to implement a Titan yeah and that item
can return basically anything with
Python but with Scott we required to
return exactly two values so the second
value can be none that's okay but it has
to be two values and the reason is that
so I could learn more or less assumes
that they are two values always and
that's how we do it but if you have a
very complex data set as I said you can
just pull it off for instance in a
dictionary and that's your X and then
you will be fine yeah I was actually
thinking about module networks in which
you have multiple input verses but as
soon as you can part it in an object and
you decompose it in the forward you're
done basically yeah that makes sense yes
yep thank you again
you mentioned doing distributed grid
search with tasks and I was wondering if
by chance you've tested with like a yarn
cluster with scorch and whether or not
you have any examples out there to
reference so I personally haven't tested
that
so I can't really answer that so das can
that use yarn yeah I think so so I would
assume that it should work but I can't
really promise that it was if someone is
here who's got the infrastructure to
test this yeah you can just contribute
to scotch maybe add something to the
documentation and so on as I said we are
all really nice people so if you have
any questions or contributions just come
to us and yeah we will do our best to
integrate that any other question before
I get down a chance all right thank you
very much